ich bin paul ronzheimer und berichte aus
der ukrainischen hauptstadt kiew peter
hell live aus dem
ausnahme
ich bin die mittelsäule und ich berichte
aus der slowakei
die titel aus russland
niebel aus new york
mit all diesen reportern werden wir im
laufe des tages sprechen gegenüber
zuerst so paul ronzheimer nach kiew und
paul ja der zehnte tag das zehnte mal
dass ich dich frage wie war die nacht
thomas die nacht war erneut mit sehr
vielen sirenen sehr viel alarm mitten in
der nacht auch einschläge allerdings
weiterhin in den vororten von kiew man
hat es laut gehört im zentrum aber um
die stadt herum da wippten die kämpfe da
sieht man auch wirklich in den sozialen
medien mittlerweile ganz ganze
straßenzüge die verwüstet sind und ich
habe gerade mit dem bürgermeister mit
vitali klitschko sprechen können und er
bestätigte mir dass die kämpfe dort
weiterhin heftig sind insgesamt was die
lage angeht ist aber auch an so einem
samstagmorgen du hast das angesprochen
am tag 10 des krieges ein gewisser stolz
bei den ukrainern zu spüren der stolz
dass sie der russischen armee weiterhin
einen solchen widerstand leisten und das
russische soldaten bislang hinter mir in
der stadt noch nicht angekommen sind
paul nun soll es eine waffenruhe geben
nach russischen angaben in mario pohl
die es seit 8 uhr heute morgen in kraft
oben der bevölkerung die gelegenheit zu
geben die stadt zu verlassen
es ist ein gutes oder ein schlechtes
zeichen
das ist sowohl ein gutes als auch ein
schlechtes zeichen erst einmal ist es
gut wenn zivilisten tatsächlich sicher
diese stadt verlassen können auch mario
pohl das ist ja absurd thomas wenn man
sich die bilder anschaut ich war da vor
14 tagen ungefähr mit dem ukrainischen
präsidenten in den straßen unterwegs
alles normal eine wirklich große stadt
dort im osten und jetzt verwüstet
eingekesselt allerdings muss man sagen
neben der frage was vollkommen richtig
und wichtig ist dass die wenigsten dort
rauskommen kann man sich auch dort die
frage gestellt wie kann es eigentlich
sein dass die russische armee bislang
diese stadt auch noch nicht eingenommen
hat also wir müssen uns ja immer wieder
klar machen
am tag zehn des krieges kreativ eine
großstadt im osten ist nicht eingenommen
und jetzt eine großstadt ist nicht
eingenommen und mario pohl auch nicht
also die einzige größere stadt die die
russische armee bislang angenommen hat
ist herr soll aber von diesen
symbolhaften städten hat die russische
armee weiterhin keine komplett unter
ihrer kontrolle
wir haben vorhin die worte von dem
ukrainischen präsidenten lenski gehört
poul den du ja auch mehrfach getroffen
hast sang der anschlag den du ihm
gegeben hast du es millionenfach auf
twitter geklickt worden er hat jetzt die
nato sehr scharf kritisiert weil sie
keine flugverbotszone durchsetzen will
ist das ist diese kritik zu scharf was
würdest du sagen
nein nichts was selensky in diesen
stunden und in diesen tagen macht würde
ich in irgendeiner form als zu scharf
bezeichnen denn natürlich ist dieser
mann hat verzweifelt natürlich führt
dieser mann sich allein gelassen
natürlich fühlt er mit seinen menschen
hier die abgeschlachtet werden
insbesondere in den städten richtung
osten insbesondere dort wo wir die
kämpfe in paris gesehen haben wo
streumunition eingesetzt wird und da
kann man es doch keinem präsidenten
verübeln kann muss man jeden präsidenten
verstehen der um hilfe bittet auf der
anderen seite gab es diese klare absage
man muss sagen natürlich fast ja aus
sicht von us präsident joe biden denn
die sorge wenn man eine flugverbotszone
einrichten würde dann würde es bedeuten
dass amerikanische flugzeuge deutsche
französische flugzeuge direkt gegen
russische truppen gegen russische
flieger kämpfen würden und damit am ende
teil des krieges werden was natürlich
aus deutscher und amerikanischer sicht
sehr sehr gefährlich ist aber wenn man
das alleine aus ukrainischer perspektive
betrachtet dann ist das der verzweifelte
hilferuf eines mannes der große angst
und sorge hat davor dass die russischen
truppen irgendwann sein land über rollen
werden denn irgendwann bei der übermacht
der russischen armee es kann tage wochen
monate dauern aber irgendwann werden die
russischen truppen hier einrollen